ce n'est pas que les anniversaires qu'on
célèbres ici chaque été on fête les
cornichons
c'est un prétexte pour se revoir entre
amis tous originaire de Moldavie
[Musique]
chez nous tout est une ferme ta vie
c'est une fête
car toutes les fois
il y a les bons plats traditionnels
qu'on cuisine assez souvent les enfants
ont aussi leur torche à accomplir c'est
plutôt lors du lavage des pots qui ont
une demande aux enfants parce qu'ils ont
la même
après les avoir fait tremper dans l'eau
pendant trois heures pour enlever
l'amertume rien de moins qu'une bonne
brasserie de cornichon
[Musique]
avec des branches de cassis Danette de
griottes si on peut en trouver de l'ail
et des carottes il y a aussi une façon
de ranger les les cornichons c'est pour
avoir le plus de cornichons parce que
pendant la fermentation les cornichons
et diminuent en volume on submerge les
cornichons avec de la saumure c'est à
dire de l'eau bouillie qu'on a refroidi
à laquelle on a ajouté une cuillerée à
table de sel par litre et ça goûte quoi
vous m'avez dit c'est pas des cornichons
à l'aneth c'est un petit peu plus sûr et
à ta cause de nos feuilles de griotte et
de quasi mais c'est très bon il y avait
quoi on mange ça ces cornichon là on
peut les utiliser les plus gros on va
les utiliser dans des salades
traditionnels et ceux qui sont plus
petit justement qui qui sont les plus
croquants on va les utiliser en tir avec
la viande plutôt comme accompagnement de
la viande
cette technique de mise en conserve
s’appelle lacto-fermentation à l'exemple
du chou qui devient choucroute les
concombres ne sont donc ni cuits ni
chauffés avec une procédure comme ça on
peut éviter même de les mettre dans le
frigo ça nécessite pas on peut les
garder tout simplement jusqu'à 10 15
degrés d'autres légumes tels que les
oignons aubergines carottes betteraves
se prête bien ce procédé qui libère les
bonnes bactéries on aime travailler fort
et s'amuser fort
je l'ai fait avec elle je l'ai faite
avec ma mère et là je l'ai fait j'ai
amené la recette à travers l'océan aussi
on ne pourrait pas se passer du décorum
lieu de Mila et ses amis ont mis leur
plus beaux atouts c'est la blouse
traditionnelle comporte tous ici que la
plupart d'entre nous on a
donc c'est nos blues qu'on a fait avec
beaucoup d'amour c'est le ciel la terre
et l'eau qui coule c'est chaque blouses
porte une histoire de chaque femme qui
la tête il faudra patienter quelques
jours pour que la saumure fasse effet en
laissant les peaux dans l'obscurité je
suis contente de mes peaux parce que la
processeur de fermentation ça bien été
on voit que la couleur des cornichons a
changé on les a laissé ouvert parce que
sinon il y aurait éclaté
pendant la fermentation nous qu'est-ce
qu'on recherche on peut avoir un goût
moyennement salé donc pour l'avoir
moyennement salive il faut qu'on arrête
la procédure de fermentation comme on va
posséder on va vider le liquide la
saumure qui est là dans les pots on va
bouillir cette saumure et on va la
mettre par-dessus les concombres chaudes
et là on va fermer les pots donc comme
ça on est sûr qu'il y a plus d'oxygène
qui rentre puis la fermentation est
arrêtée là et on les met sous une
couverture pour que le processus de
refroidissement se fasse tranquillement
lieu de Mila prend soin de ses précieux
cornichons en vue de l'hiver une tâche
imposante puisque 100 livres de
cornichon donne une soixantaine de pots
oui je suis fière parce que le processus
a bien réussi et
je pense que ma grand-mère serait fière
de moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]